foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
looking to turn a small bed into a big
payday with DraftKings Sportsbook same
game parlays you can pocket more cash
when you combine multiple bets from one
game download the app sign up for the
code Patrick get a special offer
restrictions apply see draftkings.com
Sportsbook for details Ross Tucker our
good buddy host of the Ross Tucker
football podcast also even money podcast
he was on the call for Giants Eagles
Saturday night and then he was also in
Buffalo on the field for the Bengals and
the bills and our good buddy back with
us describe the atmosphere in Buffalo on
the sidelines
oh it was awesome it was awesome Dan I
don't know I don't know what gloves I
was wearing I was wearing the gloves
that let you still be on your cell phone
but evidently those are not like water
resistant so huge mistake by me my
gloves were soaked like the whole second
half so I didn't even wear them I went
like bare-hander I had those like heat
pack things trying to warm them back up
um I I didn't really take the snow into
account that much in terms of my attire
like even that jacket I was wearing not
really like a waterproof jacket but I
survived the atmosphere was amazing it
felt like I was in a snow globe I love
being on the sideline I'm just surprised
by how the game played out I mean you're
in Buffalo it's a home game they were
decent favorites it's snowing it felt
like the stars were aligned for this
great Bill's performance and they got I
mean the Bengals came in there and just
kicked their you know what
I just I'm I'm trying to figure out as
much as I want to praise what the
Bengals did and rightfully so and Joe
burrow like what are what are the Bills
missing here
so a couple thoughts number one
they got out coached I mean let's just
be clear about this the the Bengals
seemingly on both sides of the ball were
one step ahead of the bills you know Dan
when burrow catches the ball like in the
shotgun
it feels like 90 of the time he knows
where he's throwing it before he even
gets it I mean he he actually reminds me
of like Peyton Manning he really does
like he is that smart that as soon as he
catches it he catches it out out I mean
he just is that sharp whereas Josh Allen
it feels like Josh Allen was catching
the ball I don't know how much of this
is coaching or how much of it was the
Bengals d-coordinator Lou Ann arumo
fooling Josh Allen but Josh Allen looked
like he was getting the ball Dan was
like in the backyard with his buddies
running around like trying to find
somebody open and then like rifling it
in there it just it felt like you know
the Bengals were like playing chess and
the bills were playing checkers that's
number one number two
the bills got beat up front on both
sides of the ball they don't have any
real dudes on their d-line and hurting
losing Von Miller obviously hurt but
these other guys Ed Oliver Greg Russo
like you know make a play somebody on
the d-line please at some point in the
game make a play especially against the
revamp Bengals o-line meanwhile the
bills couldn't really protect or do a
great job blocking the Bengals dealer I
mean in every game I felt like the team
that ran the ball better or was better
up front that's a team that won
and it felt like
and I know it's recency bias but Joe
burrow and Josh Allen maybe were right
there as the second best quarterback in
the NFL
is that fair to say behind Mahomes
yeah I would have said
um last year and even most of this year
I would probably have Alan ahead of
burrow I'm not sure that's the case
anymore last year in the playoffs Josh
Allen was insane I think he had like
seven touchdowns no interceptions a
crazy Pastor rating you know over 10
yards per attempt he was not that way
this postseason Josh Allen was not
locked in like burrow was yesterday I
don't know how those guys do it to be
honest I mean it wasn't like that much
snow but it was enough then I'm standing
there it's like hitting my eyes like I'm
amazed at how well the Bengals in
particular were able to throw and catch
the ball in those conditions yeah and
you know here's Buffalo they were gifted
this home playoff game you had the the
conditions there you had Demar Hamlin in
the building it it felt like this is the
storybook this is Destiny the Buffalo
Bills are going to go to Kansas City and
this time they're going to win in Kansas
City they're not going to run out of
time they're going to get their
opportunity and they're going to go to
the Super Bowl
it just felt like there was so much
attached to this that it's almost like
not only Buffalo Bills fans but America
might have felt a little bit let down
with what happened with the Buffalo
Bills I don't know what their fans
looked like or sounded like after this
game if it was I mean because you they
handled them from start to finish so it
wasn't a surprise ending here but the
atmosphere after that game was what
they were stunned they were stunned you
know I played up there a few years Dan
so I I know a lot of those people they
really did think this was going to be
their year right like after what had
happened the last couple years they
thought this was their year you know I
interviewed mixing on the field after
the game and it was 27-10 I would say
half the Bills fans had left you know in
the last couple minutes but what's
interesting is half had left
I don't know that I can ever recall
leaving a field I don't know five
minutes after the game
and seeing that many fans just sitting
in their seats just kind of stunned just
watching the field you know those people
live for that Dance I mean Western New
York Bills fans they live for that and I
think look I was I said on the air I was
surprised they got handled like that I
know you got to think the Bills fans
were shocked we're talking Ross Tucker
CBS Westwood one color analyst and host
to the Ross Tucker football podcast
joining us on behalf of DraftKings
Sportsbook you got to see the Eagles
performance against the Giants before I
talk about the Eagles
if you're the Giants what do you do
moving forward with Daniel Jones
gotta bring them back I mean what what
are your other Alternatives what are
your other options why would franchise
though I would want to franchise him and
I would want to I would hope to get
saquon Barkley for a four-year 45
million dollar deal
I totally sharing a brain then I think
the Eagles game
was the difference between
going all in on a really nice contract
for Daniel Jones versus let's just
franchise tag him and see how it goes he
was not good I mean the interception of
Bradbury was horrific he almost threw
several others it did not look like he
knew where to go with the football he
took multiple sacks he shouldn't he
missed some throws that he just couldn't
miss I mean Dan He one time ran out of
bounds for a loss of five yards so think
about that everybody in there all right
we all know that if you're outside of
the pocket you can throw the ball away
and it's not you don't lose any yards
you're allowed to do that he ran out of
bounds for a loss of five yards if I was
an offensive lineman on the Giants I
would be like what are you doing
it's year four he's played a lot of
football it's like it out of bounds yeah
you know you're allowed to do that I he
played really poorly and I think played
poorly enough that that'll give the
Giants enough pause that they'd rather
franchise tag him then give him a big
deal with multiple years of guarantees
according to DraftKings the Niners are
two and a half Point underdogs against
the Eagles where are the Eagles
vulnerable when it comes to the Niners
game plan
so I think the Niners have to run the
football and I think the Niners have to
have a lead you know if the Niners fall
behind and they get into a drop back
passing game that's not really how their
offensive line is designed and the
Eagles d-line is just ferocious and I
don't think Purdy's in a good spot if
it's a bunch of drop back pass I think
this game is critical first quarter
second quarter the Niners have to get a
lead and they have to be able to run the
football which I think they can do teams
have been able to run the ball on the
Eagles at times so I watching that game
if the Niners are able to run the ball
on the Eagles then they got a real
chance if they can't boy I feel like
they're in trouble that that will be
tough that's asking a lot of Purdy to
win that game with his arm in
Philadelphia on Sunday
what do you do if you're the Cowboys
um
it's a good question I thought that was
a huge Miss opportunity
I mean they they were every bit as good
as the Niners in that game they probably
win that game if Dak doesn't throw those
two picks I mean he threw one backed up
in his own territory gave the Niners a
field goal through another one when they
were in the red area you know and took
away three points
but you're not going to get rid of Dak
he's your guy I think primarily they
need to get another weapon on the
outside for Dak another receiver even
though they move the ball pretty well
and then I still think they could use
some help on the back end on defense
they're not far away they're they're
right there and I think they prove that
by going I mean that was a physical good
game and the Cowboys seemed like they
were pretty much every bit as good as
the Niners with the exception of those
interceptions
I'll leave you with this the high ankle
sprain with Patrick Mahomes Paulie spoke
to a doctor who deals with this and said
you know an hour after you have it you
know just adrenaline you could shoot it
up you're okay
it's the coming days that that high
ankle sprain and this doesn't just go
away
what do you do uh if you're Patrick
Mahomes in a situation like can he just
say I'm just going to be a pocket passer
I mean that's what he's going to try to
do and I don't know how well that's
going to go I mean that's not him we you
know I think it's really hard
as a player in any sport to go out there
and be someone you're really not that's
not what he is you know that's not who
he is and I can guarantee you Dan I
don't know how this guy was talking to
him yesterday I don't know how this guy
doesn't have any head coach interviews I
can guarantee you
Bengals D coordinator louanna rumo is
gonna have an awesome plan that's gonna
not allow Mahomes to get rid of the ball
quickly because the longer Mahomes has
to hold the ball the more chance there
is he has to move around or do something
which I don't know that he's going to be
able to do so the Bengals are going to
take away the quick reads quick throws
from Holmes he's going to have to try to
move I don't think he's going to be able
to do it that's a tough injury against a
really talented and well coached defense
that's going to be a tall task from
Holmes if he can't move like he normally
does better food in Philadelphia or
Kansas City
oh for this upcoming weekend because I
because yesterday Buffalo might have
been the best of the year I mean they
they came to I don't know what happened
on the field but they came to play in
The Press Box I mean it was really
impressive they had beef on weck mac and
cheese so it's like the beef that they
have in the whack in the mac and cheese
street corn they had wings from Lenova
and I knew I was gonna be on the
sideline there's no food if you're a
sideline person so I had to eat enough
pre-game at one o'clock to last me till
my drive home at eight o'clock so I went
all in Well Done by the build they also
Dan they email you
the day before with what the spread will
be which I appreciate because I like to
get my mind like I'm going to go to a
restaurant I look at the menu before I
go to the restaurant of course so the
bills let me visualize my game plan so I
can execute in the pregame so you had
your walk through with the menu yes yes
and I already was like okay I gotta get
some wings
I I've never heard of beef whack mac and
cheese but that sounds amazing it was it
was delicious it was awesome it was very
Phil I wasn't hungry at halftime thank
you to the Buffalo Bills PR and uh food
stamp that was amazing
good to talk to you as always always I'm
on the sideline that Sunday for Eagles
Niners so can't wait to talk to you
about it next Monday thank you buddy
that's our good buddy Ross Tucker CBS
Westwood one color analyst if you're
looking to turn a small bed into a big
payday draftking Sportsbook same game
parlays you can pocket more cash when
you combine multiple bets from one game
download the app sign up with the code
Patrick it's draftkings.com Sportsbook
for details